dang the last chance to see the ru
garbage live show is upon us it's a mix
of stand up comedy plus we play the
little a with the crowd yeah the last
shows of the year are December 14th in
Washington DC at the Howard Theater get
the homies get the boers let's see you
there then we're doing uh two On's
already sold out in Philadelphia at the
Filmore limited tickets left for the
second show at the Filmore that will
sell out let's get those tickets let's
party baby scoop them up love you
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's new favorite
podcast this is R you garbage oh it's
that little show we sit there with your
favorite comedians and we find that if
the gr to be classy yeah just a big old
piece of trash I'm your host H fley
coming at you on a beautiful day we're
in the back here at Aunt hoodies in the
new edition uhhuh she's upstairs making
a list and checking it twice okay my
co-host is coming at you from across the
table this is what we call in the
business a family episode just the boys
the bozos and the homies give it up for
Mr soup and salad himself Kevin James Ro
never ordered a soup Endor a salad kick
rocks with that I'm a Sammy man you're
crazy we're going to get into it uh
what's up everybody thanks for tuning in
as always please make sure you rap you
subscribe on iTunes full video available
on YouTube as you know those numbers are
TR up can I say this about iTunes what
go over there and hit the drop drop a
review let's let's let's bump those
numbers up SL the block a little it is
jumping it's jumping it's jumping it's
jumping iTunes was you know instead get
hit it everywhere full Army of garbage
attack flank them download multiple
accounts Spotify other stuff you know
what the guy who's in charge doesn't
know anything
I really iTunes and stuff like I
apologize I digress it's okay uh because
I'm going to get into the the the
[__] turkey of it here you know
anything about the greatest website ever
invented would that be patreon.com
garbage gang it out it's a party over
there you go over there you get I eons
eons that's the new word eons of bonus
content I mean it's been banging for
what two and a half years now we're
doing two episodes a week you get all
them they're all the back content you
get all that you get all the bonus
videos that we did and then also so head
over there to
www.garage.com get your tickets for the
DC show coming up at the Howard Theater
to Boer doing theaters and then we got
two shows one's already sold out at the
Filmore in Philadelphia uh that's a big
room so get those tickies cuz there's
only about maybe a hundred left and
that's going to sell out Scoopa tea or a
Zippo style lighter there that's also
very low and we're getting ready for a
new merch drop
woo tell your friends are you garbage
bikini wear
hey I'm in get Patty ready for this
summer it can be a y g come on what are
we doing gang how about a nice quick
shout out to our producer extraordinaire
the old magic man works the ones the
twos the threes and the fours he crosses
the te's and he dots the eyes he's off
the sauce but he's always on point give
it up for T-Bone McGruff and M what's up
dudes that just means he shoots
heroin Kid Likes a needle dude us
selling cut that us us selling offseason
merch is so perfect it's always at a
discount when you buy it off seon yeah I
we had mentioned I think I don't know
where we had mentioned it um might have
been we talked about the koozies that we
had made mhm and how that fly how we
like 25,000 of them when there was only
about 100 people listening to the show
thought everybody was going to buy 250
uh we got to bring those back so many
people were clamoring of for for dazies
yeah we're doing we're doing bikinis in
the winter we're doing Paras in the
summer yeah we're fli that's that's how
a dirt bag gets a deal SE the best thing
to do with the Koozies whatever City
we're going to be in uh drop them from a
helicopter yeah just DP them out the
window a [__] just drop it and I've
been jammed up with that a lot you
reminded me of that um how department
stores change the clothing every season
I've gotten jammed up with that man just
a little late in the summer they got the
fall [__] out there's no more shorts
left or vice versa just real bad
especially a DXL man I don't know what
timetable they're working on but they
are Cutthroat I'll rip a pair of shorts
out of your hand when you're trying them
on if the fall collect there they got a
thermometer it drops below 60 give them
to me I don't understand how places
don't have that we were getting ready to
go somewhere on the cruise or something
I need a couple new sets of trunks if
you're in new yeah if if if you're in a
city you would think that you know you
could you get a pair of trunks I mean
there's indoor pools you know people do
saunas the whole yard can I always get a
pair pair uh baiting suit at Target tell
you that I went to Marshalls to try to
get figuring they got something there
ain't no Seasons there quit bragging huh
Forefront of fashion well I tried to go
to like certain places they didn't have
them you know what I mean like because
it was only the winner stuff and then I
figured there's got to be a pair of
basketball shorts or something laying
around old pair of Champions or Adidas
nothing yeah got me swimming in PJs I'm
all set with my bathing suit for a while
yeah I love it yeah uh the red one yeah
mhm it's almost it's almost there which
I didn't mention this here we go uh I
forgot about thank you for bringing that
up talk about you know the big man's got
some trash Tendencies obviously we were
this was weeks ago we were in a hotel I
want to say it was Detroit or something
I was there having breakfast in the
hotel lobby lobby is a loose term by
myself right and about I don't know
let's call it on the other side of the
lobby about 35 yards
right I see aot I I feel a presence
enter from my flank a cold
chill preceded by a squad of
Stormtroopers a cold chill of anxiety
ran down my spine I heard the loud
splashings of an un toweled suit yeah so
he's just out of the pool just fresh
soaked out of the pool no shoes no shirt
no problem for the big man he's just
ruining the vibe of this breakfast nook
at this Sina in Pontiac Michigan
gentlemen oh man I think I walked by you
looked at me I was like Kevin yeah I was
like Hey I was like Hey like it was like
a deer I was like whoa I I you know just
no and I well it was kind of funny
because I could only see the top of them
cuz like there was like a breakfast bar
I did the stair thing for you I did the
fake walk you didn't and then I was like
in my head I'm like I got about two G's
that he ain't wearing those shoes and
then I see his feet his [__]
pterodactyl claws appear I'm not
bringing my uh Crocs with me that's
extra space in the luggage bare wet feet
making sure that you pick up all the
gunk along the way bare wet feet no
shirt you think I'm worried about Lobby
dirt please no but I think that there is
I hey you're big you're bold you're
beautiful I dry it off very well and I
sure wouldn't have killed you then I
would then it would have been another
wet piece of clothing in my bag I and I
Hey listen I had to use the ice bag to
put my shorts in till we got to the next
year B&B with a dryer didn't work I I
understand that yeah in my room yeah
that was
weird man um thing was rattling all
night but dud that I mean that take
that's a bold I think anybody
topless guy or girl walking through
breakfast like walking through a
continental breakfast is a tough look
they had to pull up
no one else was walking I dude I sat
there for two hours that's cuz they
weren't getting after it I got up early
and did my laps did my medling right I
understand this is a thing that you're
going to put your foot down you have to
your med are just singing mining songs I
tell you my butterfly is all right I
don't know if it was the pool or what
but I was really coming out of that
thing you have to concede something
that's a lot a gentleman of your stature
walking wet through families eating
breakfast that's a lot towel over the
shoulder towel over the shoulder I'll
give him
that that's all right what it's like I I
think it was no it was the middle of
November in Michigan dude what are we
talking about that's not all right he's
set in the scene for a good time man I
he doing this
thing Twist and Shout pool's warm I'm
I'm back there grilling obviously we
weren just getting buns be right back we
weren't it a Four Seasons I'll give you
that I stepped outside for 5 minutes too
to get the cold felt good it was almost
like a cold plunge were you were you
smoking no no not after my
laps I don't believe that I didn't bring
my I didn't bring my heaters with me oh
you didn't have any heaters I remember
that smoking my this guy knocking on my
can I get a heater I'll be over he's
texed me can I get a heater I'll be over
in 30 seconds you want to have one I
don't like being right next to you yeah
oh no hear you scratching around over
there uhhuh I can hear you coughing
and
sounds like the [__] cheaper creepers
is coming through my curtains I don't
like it I want to be on separate
separate wings
dude you got a lot of balls what do you
mean I I I didn't I didn't trash you for
that I just he on the you got to let him
know all those stiffs are in there doing
their business lunch or business
breakfasts and [__] like that saying
you're you're ruining deals you're not
even a part of people are getting turned
off don't do it lady they're drinking
hot apple cider and donuts bringing in
the cold air Here Comes uncle Hank
[__] treating it like it's the
goddamn poop deck out
here listen I I I I accept you and love
you for who you are it's a very you
thing and I'm I'm not I just wanted to
bring it to uh let's bring it to the end
give that a few more months bring it to
the what you'll be sliding off your seat
eating your bacon egg and cheese man
that what they threw down that bacon egg
and cheese it wasn't eggs it wasn't
bacon I'm pretty sure it wasn't cheese
but man they threw a garlic aoli on that
thing that blew your thick this chemical
Burger is
great yeah anyway that's neither here
nor there this is what we call a family
episode as I mentioned the beginning of
this program not disparage my my
physique I wasn't disparaging your
physique it was more the behavior I
don't I you're lucky I gave you a peak
buy I've seen too much of it all right
I'm just I got a real PE I got I got you
real good did you see him full frontal
no no I turn around oh man yeah I had to
grab something that he was in the shower
I had to grab something out of classic
bit so it was it was a a lion's toe tub
what are they called something like that
Lion's claw so when the curtain went all
the way around so he comes in he comes
in he's like hey you know I got to get
my toothbrush or brush my teeth I'm like
oh come on in the curtain's drawn but I
left the back open and the and the sink
was right behind me so when he walked in
looked at the right he saw all cheek
meat it's
shockingly small amount you think so
yeah well I I there's a there's a a
theory I have on bigger
guys your butt gets smaller somehow I
got I don't have a nice butt no you I
would say you barely have a butt yeah
huh it's just like legs with a split
little baby slit yeah Frankie flat butt
over here that would be your mob
name yeah it's like Frankie flat but
looks like he was in a vice or something
yeah get all smooshed in yeah I thought
I had nice cheeks though I got to start
wearing tighter jeans show it off a
little bit are you sure bringing that
milkshake
uh anyway Family episode as you know
gang when you sign up for the old
patreon you can have a question read on
the air with uh me
and what Kevin oh man you really know
how to get under my
skin uh all right this one's from Team
Stevens longtime $10 homie never had one
read when organizing the apps on your
phone is it garbage to include the
lottery apps with your personal banking
and title it personal finance
hey you're staying on top of it I I
respect that mine are all over the place
and I swear to God some of them
disappear I don't know what happened to
one of them it it's not anywhere it's
not I I scroll over it's not anywhere
but then when I search it it comes up
you probably throw it in a folder
somewhere I don't think so I look
through all those weird freaks me out
yeah I'm ruined uh I I'm the kind of guy
I have a sh I have a [__] ton of apps
that like what happens when they offload
it or something it's like I have to
download the app to use it when they
offloaded what's that all what does that
mean uh you have I'm looking at you the
guy's in charge of all the equipment the
you have an older iPhone so I would
assume that your memory is they're like
saving memory by pulling some of the
apps off and then bringing them back
yeah there's like three apps I use I got
to just I want to I want to [__]
clean slate get all that [__] off but
then when you need it you start
downloading them again like a
yeah I have one uh a worship app that's
pretty good it's a game you're like a
you're like a like a Navy ship and you
go around pretty cool sounds it sounds
riveting Jesus some of those free games
are actually pretty sweet so they try to
get you to spend money but I don't
budget's cut my defense budget's cut I
remember when I sended my boys out there
when I salute them all gentlemen do your
best it's pretty cool you you get to be
a helicopter and fly around when we
first moved up here you he moved up 6
months before me and then I was getting
here and brought you into the city okay
I was there waiting for you scumbag what
yeah when the day that you got here I
met you on 23rd Street four hours late
no you didn't yes you I did I met you
you cuz I was in a movie I think I was
watching Superman Returns if that makes
sense dude you did not meet me I didn't
meet you on 23rd Street the day I moved
here yes you did I don't know what to
tell you that's not the case he moved
here in
1986 when did Superman Returns come out
the 80s no not no no the one with
Brandon Roth give it a goog 2013 that
dropped I want to say in the summer of
2013 oh 2006 wa that's a cartoon no The
Return of Superman it doesn't matter
this whole thing never happened I don't
know what to tell you I don't think I
ever saw the film I've never even been
to New York City what what are you gonna
say you uh I remember
you it was very uh Forest gum showing up
in Vietnam with uh Lieutenant Dan like
was everything's about your feet out
your socks keep your feet clean make
sure they don't get wet but you were
like what kind of games you got on your
phone I'm like why you're like those
Subway rides get long and lonely you got
to be able to play games I downloaded
like some match brick breaker type
bootleg game that man got me through a
lot of stole train rides
3:00 a.m. yeah [__] snoozing on the
train it's good oh man all right let's
see here I didn't know there was a
lottery app uh I think some c yeah
obviously thinking about rolling the
dice on that what getting into the
lottery a little bit more ah I can't I
got that gambling problem they talk
about uh yeah I just keep chasing it
then the fact you could do it at every
gas station I get that's the problem
when I get scratchers it's like I like
it there I like the action there it's F
we'll the road sometime yeah but get
another guy doing it yeah just uh chew
it up a little
bit the access to it's too easy for me
with with all the with all the road
trips we take I do a lot of I bet a lot
on football on the road and then it it
categorizes it by State and it looks
like I am the biggest in jail you're
just driving around to get it putting it
all in the liines dude
J it's like nine states I like to do it
at the
stadium like to have boots on the ground
when I lose my money I'm up see how the
quarterback's feeling uh all right this
one's from Tyler are you garbage if
every new person you meet you point out
what celebrity they look
like you know who you look like I D all
the time that's a all the cuz a lot of
times it's most of the times it ain't
great yeah you know what I mean it's
very rare that there's like a Brad Pit
look alike walking around like you know
who you look like Brendan Frasier now
like oh [__] dude he still looks good
yeah he's doing good yeah he looks
better than he did he had a rough that
was a fat suit for the whale no not done
in the whale there was a he had some
sort of something look good that young
kid no ass
though [__] flat ass over here uh
yeah I get I don't think I get anybody
anymore well now I don't think now you
get online is the I used to think you
look like somebody I couldn't remember I
tell you Bruce WS your best friend I
tell you Bruce WS no I tell you Bruce
Wills everyone
once in a while to keep your keep your
self-esteem ey uh no I got uh College I
would get Michael bé when he dropped
like high school or college I was
thinner obviously Temple School for the
Blind Michael bé you got when I was
younger younger and thin when I was a
literal different person that's what I
would get from multiple people this you
weren't thin in college you were a por
no College there was
a sophomore year
sophomore year I was thin I was real
poor and had a real bad drinking problem
march to may I was killing it well once
I once I moved back home to Denise's for
the summer blow back up get them Pub
Wings in me and stuff like that but man
when I was living off five bucks a day
and half that had to go to a [__]
hurricane 40 Michael bé yeah I'm just
telling you what I I listen I'm just
telling you what I got
reaching well this isn't me it's not
like I brought this out you know what
I'm going to I'm trying to push this
narrative that I Michael bé Toby who
would you get oh I get my my thing's all
stink it's all hair based it's all Blake
Anderson some Muppet the Flying Tomato
oh that's a pretty good one even like
eyes and everything that's not bad Shawn
White Mr Shawn White that ain't bad and
then and then every now and again it's
always a drunk lady and they'll be like
like Little Dicky and then I push him
down a flight of
stairs you kind of do you kind of he's
all right you got Little D Vibes shut up
shout out to them this episode is
brought to you by better help shout out
to it when you're making your shopping
list for the holiday season remember
it's time to give a gift to yourself and
that gift is peace of mind whether it's
taking a nap whether it's treating
yourself to your favorite coffee or
getting started with therapy give
yourself some love this holiday season
gang if you're going through something
reach out to better help because they
can help and Pa you up with a license
therapist you could do it from the
privacy of your own home you don't got
to wait in some waiting room you could
do it with a phone call you could do it
with text you can do it with video it's
absolutely fantastic yeah these times
are tough for everybody family no f
everything there's a lot of stuff sroll
around if you need someone to talk to
I've used it in the past talk therapy is
a great tool I can't be a bigger
advocate of it use it for shortterm
longterm whatever you want if you're
having a rough couple of weeks get in
there vent a little bit if you're having
a tough type you're unpacking some stuff
from your childhood which I may or may
not have done you can do that too uh
looking at me for it you can do video
phone even message better help is
designed to fit your lifestyle style uh
if you need to switch therapist for any
reason you can easily swap no additional
charge in the season of giving give
yourself what you need with better help
visit betterhelp.com garbage today to
get 10% off your first month that's
betterhelp
hp.com garbage do it Kip this is
manscaped shout out to me you know what
I want for Christmas this year clean
balls smooth balls well baby come over
my house we can do two for the price of
one that smell good and are delicious
talking about fresh nuts gang we're not
talking about the ones you get in the
street over there in New York City
talking about the ones you got down
below you and do that with the
performance package 5.0 which includes a
lawnmower 5.0 Ultra body trimmer then
you got the weed whacker 2.0 ear and
nose trimmer MH then you got the crop
Soother to keep it all nice and smoo a
cool breeze on a springtime day baby get
over to the manscape gang they the best
yeah I've been using it for years I keep
the twig and berries nice and clean do a
little butthole do a little nose do
whatever you want Little B I've seen it
nice I tighten up the face with the same
thing use one no one cares take hop in a
shower scrub it off the lawn mower 5.0
Ultra does all the heavy lifting with
the two next gen blade heads it's even
waterproof so you can knock out uh while
you're you're shaving routine while
you're in the shower and here's the
turkey gang get 20% off and free
shipping with the code garbage
manscape.com that's 20% off with free
shipping at manscape.com use the code
garbage do it yo this hurricane 40 I
never heard of that that looks like dog
Biz you never heard of a hurricane 40 no
have you never heard a hurricane no
Whoa man those are two and M you comes
the story of the
hurricane what were you then what 40s
were you banging with
Cobra oh kind of Devil's juice is that
yeah the thing with the Cobra was once
you opened it you had three minutes
before it went flat oh man the bottom of
a 40 hence is oo it was never cold swill
swill yeah really had a power shake it
up had a power through that shake it up
like a nesquick yeah yikes hurricanes
old e and Colt 45 which wasn't bad we
did uh Hurricane's ey her first freshman
year we got introduced to Steel reserves
which claimed they had extra gravity and
we called our they had they had like
poppy seeds in them we caught ourselves
astronauts dude we would [__] just
sit there and get [__] wasted all
yeah those things are tough uh they're
not good none of them are good and then
Hur we moved to hurricanes cuz
hurricanes were 250 a pop so five bucks
lights out go to a go to a party like a
keger five bucks for a cup there're your
[__] your 10 bucks in on the night
and you're blacked out let me tell you
you're getting is to leave that party
you are creeping people
out stand leaning on a wall smoking
inside the slogan for Hurricane should
be hurricane that's good creeping
hurricane get your creep
on uh all right this one's from Skyler
is a garbage if three of the meals you
cook best are from the maror miles
Country Cookbook shout out to the Texas
bison chili I didn't know there was one
oh yeah there's a maror cookbook well
they shut you can't have any of that
stuff anymore but it was all the marel
miles it was the cookbook the raft the
school bag to I don't remember the
cookbook what was that recipe uh the
Tyson B Texas B and chili it's probably
all right yeah that sounds delicious
yeah it was very like uh I mean
obviously the it was like B meat I
assume Buffalo yeah but I'm sure they're
putting you can any kind of ground
ground chuck in there place I used to
work at made venison chili it was really
good I don't know if I've ever had
venison it's good I I yeah I can't do it
it's too weird to me cute little deers
this marbo miles cookbook is sick it's
got to be it's called morning fires and
evening lights the mar bro Country
Cookbook man I'm telling you it's only
10 bucks on
eBay uh Toby get my credit
card little little dash at tobacco bang
had three cigarette
butts yeah this casserole is mostly
filters a pinch of Ash I know it's I
know it's because that you can't smoke
inside anymore but uh the art of putting
a cigarette out in a plate of food is is
really lost I don't know I obviously I I
I remember we were a smoking section
family a cousin or an uncle or it might
have been my dad putting out a cigarette
in like a straight dippy egg in like an
OV easy egg yeah and just the smell and
the look of that was horrifying yeah no
um we used to do a ketchup splattered
everywhere uh dude I used to read that
maror Miles book I mean like like it was
the kitty
City Christmas catalog Edition I would
flip through that and I would count my
menthal muffins look good I would put my
miles in stacks of hundreds and I had my
dad go to my dad was smoked my dad
smoked Reds my stepmom smoked Light 100s
uh so I'd collect them and then he would
go to work and every I mean construction
company in the 90s everybody's cranking
heaters sure so they would collect them
all for me so I had like 50 people
[__] on the street
was out there earning earning for
earning for the boss's boy that is a
weird that's a weird thing for the
boss's kid usually five bucks some candy
a lollipop marel miles and I would put
them I would put them in paper clips I
had them in like stacks of like 25
you're getting those in those weird
Combs you get at the barber shop
remember those the hand grip ones oh no
those things I thought they were for
pets I didn't know what those were I
want one of them so bad I just went
somewhere uh I got my haircut in my
local Hometown when I was down there
visiting Denise popped in for a for a
for a do you doing all right job uh cuz
usually they Jam you up no they did all
right they did all right I grew up going
there and uh give you a Skippy
cut uh don't know how to use the
scissors
just yeah it was good it was all right
um those guys always kick of cologne too
but they had them there they had those
things there I'm like this has to be
left over from the 80s dude who's who's
banging with those anymore I've never
seen anybody use one mm ever no we were
never allowed to buy anything at the
like you know they would have product
and stuff I think one time that's always
a ripoff that's always the markups crazy
I think one time we got it for it was
like this pom I think it was when Pomade
first dropped and like you couldn't get
it at like the Super Fresh of the acne
changed my life yeah like Pomade
literally changed my life mhm for the
better sure okay got addicted to it yeah
lost my first wife cuz a Pomade yeah
dude I was you don't know what it was
like in the 90s it was all gel I I dude
I I rocked gel it wasn't until High
School gel and hair spray like rock hard
hair and if you if that dried and you
messed with it you might as well been
wearing sheetrock on your head you were
Dusty yeah dude we would shave we in
fourth grade you up it was like the the
straight up the down and straight like
Elementary School and Junior High that
was cool like the straight up spiked
vert ramp no but like this was down and
then this was up oh I know what you're
talking yeah yeah yeah with maybe I
don't know 14 o of dep hair gel in there
yeah or dude there was I remember this
one stuff Schwarz go remember it was
yellow that you you know it yeah that
was the name of it I can't hang out I
got Schwarz
goof Schwarz goof storman Norman that's
what you were rocking kids a goddamn
patreon I'll tell you that no this stuff
got to be got to be glued oh that's
that's by the brand schs cough yeah that
stuff that is conc styling spiking GL
and it smells like
candy dude that's concrete you got to
wash your hands immediately
yeah yeah rock that ain't going anywhere
no that stuff was all right maybe I'll
switch back to that it's like Bondo yeah
yeah it's like superg glue there's like
a Time the second it comes out of the
bottle there's a timer and you got to
act quick you guys ever Ed that glue
that comes in two separate tubes and
then it mixes in the front that's an
epoxy no
that was stuff was for spaceship
dangerous dude dangerous see the fumes
kicking off that stuff you're like I
shouldn't be touching this no model glue
was bad too I don't know if you guys
remember model glue I love the smell of
model
glue I don't that no model has ever been
built anywhere near me that'll get you
ripped that'll tune you up do that'll
get you where you need to be you got to
do that in you got to use that in an
open air environment kids let me tell
you that you never did
models a couple as I got older um no
model rockets cuz I thought that was
cool for a second but they never lived
up to what you know launching those
Rockets but I remember some real it was
like say after school and you can launch
rockets and this guy who didn't work at
the school showed up in a lab coat to
launch rockets with us I was like buddy
we're next to the swing set and this
thing's you know lab code get out my uh
kid I grew up with his dad was into the
little mini airplanes like the ones that
were like gas powered they were like
early drones sure but they look like
those things yeah dude black smoke
coming from them and stuff tried to take
me out to the football field and do that
with him I was like nah I'm good we did
that I got a I got a helicopter for this
was like Prime divorce my dad was really
really [__] pulling out all the stops
to win Chopper was it big no it's
probably like this big or whatever
that's pretty cool you know with like
the those ones a few Christmases ago
were pretty sweet the like they were
like little they were remember the
little indoor drones that you'd get them
yeah yeah those little Choppers they
were pretty cool they have this thing
now where it's like a ball and
it it it floats around the house oh good
let's let's get more robots in the what
are we doing we got to not be given
these robots access to our homes man no
I'm with it who's this D I don't know
Skynet man this is how it starts yeah
whatever well we're already in it you
know what I mean [__] at least have
the cool toys if you're going if they're
going to take over at least enjoy them
till they take over that's what I'm
saying uh five of them dragging you out
of your
house I wouldn't be talking [__] they're
probably
listening we are surrounded by a lot of
Technology bunch of drones outside [__]
uh all right this one is Colombian
sandblasted nostrils this is uh uh long
time never have one R is it garbage to
reuse garbage bags I know the answer but
my aunt doesn't that's
crazy I mean I don't get it you'd have
to be the only reason I would ever do is
I was really in a pinch if there was a
lot of trash and I needed I would go
down where are you dumping it then you
just dumping it in a trash can I think
if I had a guess it would go trash can
into the trash can that you that you
you're just raw dogging it out to the
side they don't like that though
cuz then they but if it's raw dogged in
the trash can they go to dump it it gets
everywhere unless they got the the they
got that AI Robots coming they don't
look in that thing they don't look in
the trash can they just dump it they
don't give a [__] no but I'm saying a
lot of times that blows away or like if
it's not contained in a bag that trash
can get all over the place in the truck
no even outside of the truck you got the
lid dummy I know but when they go to get
it they [__] they don't they they also
don't care so they bang it once or twice
and then throw it then there's a bunch
of loose [__] trash on the street
bunch of Slim Fast cans rolling around
what for a minute Patty was um she was
reusing
Ziplocs and they were
greasy yeah that's not I mean that's
insane to me yeah that's like that's
sent me to school with one a couple no
called Child Protective Services stained
red Ziploc with a ham and cheese in or
salami and cheese in it no used to love
a salami and cheese I yeah not a mustard
no Patt not for the kid thin
slice um tight all right let's see here
uh this one's from Christian Parker ever
been really into Sons of Anarchy no yes
this year this year whack I went back
holds up first first watch uh Second
Time Around and I got to tell you I at
the exact moment I stopped watching the
last time the exact moment I stopped
watching this time really falls apart in
that third season
I do love um lady that played Peggy
Bundy can't think of her name off top of
my head yeah I can't either Brant actor
very good very very good she was Katie
seagull yes nice pull yeah married to
Ron Perman no sure in the in real life
yeah no I don't think so I thought they
were love Ron Pearlman ah really all
right you better watch your he come down
here and tune you up yeah that's what I
don't like about him always [__]
tough gu it don't internet I saw him
walking his dog one time you [__]
Flex on him no he's big dude yeah he's a
I mean he would [__] tune me you know
what he was brilliant in drive you ever
see Drive yeah I can't pull him though
he was um what's his
name uh Mel Brooks's not Mel Brooks Mel
Brooks not Mel Brooks may maybe I
haven't seen drive it was Albert
Brooks's uh side like like his part his
partner n yeah I don't know Albert
Brooks was brilliant in that too so was
everybody yeah what do you have on KY
seagull's husband he's somebody he's a
badass I think uh
CTS
vaget no what Kurt
stutter wh what was that pretty sweet
name nothing on
that oh there you go yeah all right I
was a little late to the game on that
one my bad Jesus Christ come on T-Bone
uh Kurt stutter she was also married to
Jack White at one point who no of the
White Stripes get out of here that's
crazy oh man we got the worst In The Biz
I'm telling you dated the Olen twins for
a while wait is this say she's Asian
what the [__] yeah she wasn't married to
Jack White no way they might have dated
though that's not that crazy wait no
she's his mom she's his mom yeah but
this doesn't look like Jack White of The
White Strip off googleing
details I think he's doing bad so we
stop asking him to Google stuff that's a
brilliant like he's sabotaging it I wish
I just stink sometimes you're fantastic
but when you're off you're off I'm
really missing here yeah well it's you
know Katie seagull husband comes up it's
like nine guys and one of them's her son
I don't know what's going on her son
might be an actor as well anyway didn't
get into Sons of Anarchy I was real wary
of those uh FX shows they were good man
they were putting out good [__]
content back listen I [__] on Breaking
Bad for years and then watch it during
the pandemic and absolutely loved it so
I'll go back and check it out I did
dress up like Jack one Halloween from
Sons of Anarchy the main character you
do not look like him no you that kid's a
scorcher yeah he's like a Brit or
Australian yeah he's British man they
kill it they they can really do the
flip-flop they murder it yeah I got to
give it to them think he's a Midwestern
farm boy or something like that but then
I'm I'm an idiot like I don't once some
like to go oh he's British I go and then
I can see it so easily you hear when the
accent slips out yeah or just even a
little twang on a word hear that the
original man with Hugh Jackman they do
one take where they shoot it from behind
they shoot from behind with him and Anna
pacan in the car and he's like listen
Kade like it pops out a little bit it's
really bad in the courtroom scene in
Boondock Saints one of the dudes is like
give us you're tired you're poor and
it's so bad
dude shout out to Boondock Saints by the
way fantastic film yeah fan had to fre
tax I have to have DVD oh was also The
Boondock Saints for Halloween it was a
rough College for me I was you were both
of
them I was the size of them uh yeah had
the whole whole nine yards that's a good
college costume because then you can put
Pennies on blacked out dude's eyes yeah
it's also it's like it was really just
sunglasses Sinister yeah can kill a guy
uh it was really just a peac coat which
were big then anyway a white T-shirt uh
like a the a rosary glasses and I think
we put the have you made a move on a
winter coat this year year I bought one
last year in Germany what is it is it
that quilted one no why you going to
make are you going to get one of them
I'm you can't you made fun of me for man
you are a flip flopper I already have
one I wore it last year it's lighter
it's a Nautica one but I I'm calling
dibs on the peac coat cool everybody
cool cool what's the next question H I
don't think we gonna have to run that up
to flag CH I also already have a peac
coat it doesn't fit you and it's like 5
years old damn he's
right
I was in your closet this morning it's
new and doesn't fit okay and you don't
wear anything do you even own a winter
coat yeah I do I bought that coat I
didn't realize it's two hoodies melted
together I didn't I bought that that
hoodie that coat that I didn't know was
quilted all right well you're using it
for another year I got dibs on the peac
coat yeah I I did the peac coat like a
decade ago I'm off the peacat cool the
problem with the peac
coat they're not a it's not great for
the winner no it's they're not that's a
glorified hoodie they they don't keep
you warm I could bring back to Jay
Whistler I still got it do you have it
yeah that thing man I I know we have
footage of that somewhere I have to get
it he showed up looking like castanza on
this $9 jacket he he bought dude he
bought a jacket on Amazon it was before
anybody was doing that before anybody
was buying he got Amazon clothes it was
called Jay Whistler this thing looks
like it took [__] it was bulletproof
dude dude we were smacking them in it
and [__] it was the coldest winter ever
and we were we were on the street
smelled like tires dude it was bad
smelled like old rubber yeah I couldn't
smoke with it on it I swear to God it
was bad go up like a Christmas tree it
was bad news but it was like 20 bucks
and it was so warm it was so
warm we would always do that cuz we had
uh no money that'll fit me again that
might fit you yeah uh we had no money
dude that's crazy you saved that that
that you wore that N9 years ago and you
saved it open to get back into it one
day oh I got a ple you've been lugging
that thing around Queens I got some 36
Old Navy jeans that I have some
unfinished business with well I mean 36
you're a long way from be a minute to be
a minute buddy I'm a 34 yeah or 33 these
days maybe they're 38s loose
fit what brand they're Old Navy oh that
that might as well be a 48 dude what are
you talking about they are giving they
ain't your o cut oh man that's no H&M
cut talk about charity work that's pro
bono they let it all hang out um I got
like two pair of them up
there tight on the ankle in a glass case
says break in case a
miracle if H freeze is
over throw EAS on K but talk about
butcher box baby buter box best in a b
butcher box you know them you love them
we've been talking about them forever
they're one of our absolute fav talking
about top Quality Meat delivered right
to your door we're talking about what
grass-fed grass finish we're talking
free range we're talking wild caught
wild caught no hormones no antibiotics
you get to pick what you want to have
sent to you or you can let them do their
thing which I highly recommend let them
curate it a little bit send you some
chops send you some chicken send you
some salmon it's a good time they got
humanly raised beef pork chicken seafood
delivered right to your doorstep they
partner with folks who shared who share
their high standards and can offer the
Great deals on high quality meat like
free range USDA certified organic
chicken wings baby o I mean they they
send me I I need a meat freezer for the
amount of meat these guys send us it's
fantastic shout out to butcher box we
love it we everything we make is from
butcher box right now for a limited time
new members get three pounds of chicken
wings in every order for a year when
they sign up gosh damn it they're gift
you open up a sports bar for a limited
time lot of chicken new members get
three L PBS of chicken wings in every
order for the year when they sign up
you'll even get a recipe inspiration
guides tips how to make the most of your
box sign up today at butcherbox.com
use the code ay to get free chicken
wings for a year it's a lot of wings
that's three pounds of free range
organic chicken wings free in every
order for a year when you sign up at
butcherbox.com use the code a y do three
lbs that's crazy okay let's talk about
displate shout out to dis dis dis
displate let me ask you ladies a
question out there which guy you going
to bang the guy with a regular poster on
his wall That's all Dogge geared and
worn out or a guy with a nice metal
poster from Dish playay that's who's
closing deals and they got the licensing
agreements they got it all so they got
the Marvel they got the Star Wars they
got the sports teams they got everything
hangs on the wall in about two seconds
got magnets on there so you're not
ripping the wall out when you move then
you're not getting your secur deposit
back then you got to go to the
landlord's house and banging the door
and try to get it from me you're going
to give it to you but with this plate
get yourself laid and get your
securities BS back there you go God Dam
what else do you need uh they got like
big man said they got it all we got a
Seinfeld one out there uh out there in
the studio Jerry
SFI uh it's fantastic you can save up to
30% off when you click the link in the
show notes baby to make it easy for you
your discount will be applied
automatically to your cart when you
click the link and what a what you got
you got little ones you got nieces you
got nephews what a great gift make them
to talk to town everybody else is
getting regular nerd posters get
something cool let them go to school and
flex on these dudes there you go use a
code garbage when you visit displate.com
that's displate.com code garbage or
click the link in the show notes do it
all right let's see this one's from Euro
TR Johnny Cash uh is it garbage to keep
your Pepto in the
refrigerator I get that I thought we we
always did no yeah our Pepto I'm not
saying you had to I'm not I I'm not
saying cold in the Rocks call it reminds
me of the doesn't do anything by the way
Pepto no I hate to BGE American company
you're probably you have like chronic
issues that's Pepto ain't going to work
I got yeah Pepto are you supposed to
keep it
cold uh no no yeah you can but it's fine
people say it tastes better but it's
fine to leave uh room temp I love the
taste cuz there's a candy that tastes
like that they're called like red
buttons or something like that I think
you were just eating red buttons no
they're or uh Whistler silver dollars or
something like that like they're like
whatever that flavor is oh like Necco
wafer esque yeah but they're thicker
yeah remember yeah I could crush a box
of those yeah they were any yeah those
in
um they did have the the silver dollars
they were they were like gummy candy but
they were real tough they'd rip your
fillings out they were awesome but they
were Cherry can't remember what they
were called I want to say hot buttons
but that ain't right you know it was all
right cold real cold
wait maax
amoxicillin you ever have the liquid
amoxicillin the pink stuff oh my God
I'll do
too round of round of a MOX still for me
and the boys here yeah it was all
right man if you were sick that has a
Pepto Vibe a spearmint a pink spearmint
flavor if you're sitting there and
you're jammed up not feeling well but
you know you got one of them coming at
you around 400 p.m. yeah
doggy loved it kids cough medicine and
stuff like that and diam tap oh forget
about it yeah grape diam tap get you
back in here real good I got in so much
trouble one time cuz I drank a half a
bottle of cough medicine my mom freaked
out yeah no [__] drug me to the drugg me
to the pharmacist scream he brought me
home and pinned me down on the kitchen
floor and poured it down my throat ah
traumatizing just me and her that's a
waste of good DXM
trying to get lifted here th come on do
you're a buzz smoking turbo
blunts come on Patty doing with
me uh yeah damn um I [__] I
also didn't start taking pills till way
later in the game I fought it wild stff
them in chicken tenders for you yeah no
it was like piece of cheese I remember a
doctor rolling his eyes Children's
Tylenol wasn't too bad either that was
all right if he didn't feel good that
gave you that was you know almost like a
sweet Dart uh yeah I crush him up for me
they take two spoons and crush them and
just put like a little eye dropper of
water right down I remember my dad when
I finally took adult Tylenol was so fed
up he had just got home from work he was
in the kitchen I was sick as [__]
freaking out all day cuz I wouldn't take
it and it was just like the time where
it's like all right you're sick yeah
have to transition over into this you
got 106 fever they got to get you
straightened out and he was just like
just do it and then I just did it and
boom why did we think we were going to
choke I don't know I did it I remember
the last time I did it I took two Advil
and I sucked on them I'm like what it'll
be the same my mom's like you cannot
suck on Advil why they put the candy
what are you talking about it's all
going to the same place though right I'm
sure you can right medically tongue
tongue looking like Swiss cheese that
always bothered me wait can you suck on
Advil you got to be right it's got to do
the same thing it probably tastes
horrible once the candy coating gets
done H yeah they didn't no Blow Pop
irritate your mouth or your throat but
come on what is it I got a sore throat
anyway I'm sick that's what the ice pops
are for sure Patty get me a cray Apple
straighten me out uh a little piece of
toast with a little butter on it yeah
whole wheat so good strowman straight up
ginger ale and toast that hit and when
like if you couldn't because there was
always like you woke up feeling so bad
you were shitty there was like a
linebacker there was pain and stuff like
that or you you're like you know what I
mean but then when you could when you
could finally get to the point where you
could do some Ginge and some [__]
toast man that oh felt you could feel
your body being replenished throw on a
double shot of He-Man wrap me up little
tomato soup grilled cheese with some
powdered sugar on it hell hello ma was
real good ma wa whoo whoo wo whoo wo W
powdered sugar on what on grilled cheese
yeah what what yeah no you're crazy no
it stand I mean not all the time but
sometimes sure I've never heard of that
when why what was wrong with you you're
thinking French toast I'm not I'm
thinking P I'm thinking grilled cheese a
little pwed sug what yeah dog that is
not right have yourself a nice little
treat man no oh yeah who your mom was
doing that sure
I mean it's I Googled it I might need a
phone call on that it's not bad Hank
it's not my favorite but it but it is
very French toasty it's nice H you can't
dip it you then cannot dip the the
grilled cheese in the soup which is yeah
that'd be crazy I know but it is great I
mean there is uh I mean a lot of them
are coming up to Monte kisto style love
a Monte meat in them um when I found out
those things existed man yeah so you're
down for the money kisto this is you
know that's French toast dude it's
different grilled cheese that's I think
you're making it up I'm not that's nuts
yeah I don't I don't cosign that that's
just weird it's like your cousin's
kissing um tell my mom that back it's
it's a Carolina Cristo dude I don't what
to tell you that's pretty good well
that's not bad all right why do you why
you lead with the marketing yeah right
if you would have thrown a cool name at
me I would have been on board the [__]
[__] you know me I like a good name
advertising junkies over here give me a
Twist give me a spin tell me why I'm
buying this
thing car Carolina Cristo all
right grilled cheese with sugar on it
powdered um all right let's see here
this one's from Major Woody shout out to
you it's all right is it garbage if you
wait till Saturday to do your grocery
shopping because the local grocery store
gives you 10% off if you wear your
team's Jersey sweet that's all right cuz
dude as a guy who worked at a grocery
store on Sunday football season Sundays
if you knew you were getting out for the
game and everybody's coming in and
buying the tailgate stuff buying the
party stuff the party trays the [__]
sodas the snacks it was like it was just
getting cold out a good Suburban grocery
store on a Saturday or Sunday when they
first open it's pretty fantastic strust
there's a buzz in the air it would be
busy enough but not too busy so you were
like bus you know you were like moving
and stuff and there was just a Vibe of
like go Birds everybody's coming up
talking like you think they got it the
red whatever you know what I mean it was
a very it was a city fulfilling Vibe it
was great my I wouldn't have been I
wouldn't have been good behind the
register my anxiety would have been too
too too bad of trying you know like
that's what made me that's why that's
why I was good at they're bitching
they're complaining they're you know
what's going on up there I'm taking
bites I got a soft pretzel going on guys
up there counting grapes
no that's what made me good at it the
anxiety of like would you have people
yelling at you and stuff like that no I
was quite good it's well documented on
this program how good I was I was very
very very very good people get real
impatient in grocery store lines oh yeah
real impatient yeah and this I'm talking
this is the day of the checks too people
still writing
checks dealing with that I wonder if you
could get to like lay headquarters or
you know the the ruffle Factory and see
if the football season creates a spike
in chip sales I bet it goes nuts course
what are you nuts yeah of course yeah
that the summer 4th of July Tuesday yeah
uh yeah of course man chips go up start
of the school year yeah dude big
anything with parties for sure
football's the best football's pretty
cool don't mind it
um uh but that would be yeah where you
watching the game there was a thing also
too uh I remember sad guy that comes in
and just gets like one frozen dinner and
a can of cat food yeah you're like what
the
[__] you call a friend or
something H yeah uh I remember to hating
and it's it's this weird thing I was uh
I was in the BBS and it was a cold night
and cold night in the BBS kind of
depresses me a little bit cuz it
reminded me of like being a kid Sundays
when you had to go in early my dad would
pick me up I could be like you know at a
buddy's house and he would pick me up
and it was always uh what was the game
all
941 yeah WIP WIP was a sports talk so it
was on 941 WP always broadcasted the
games and Merill ree right pulling his
name correctly the voice of the voice of
the birds for a long time uh and man it
just I believe he still is if I'm not
crazy I haven't listened you know yeah
um but uh he uh getting in that car no I
had school it's getting dark earlier
it's cold I [__] it was like this
pavlovian response I'd be [__]
depressed by the time I got home
probably didn't do your homework they
didn't do the no I got that coming up no
I got some [__] dinner I got to eat
that ain't chicken
tenders I just [__] hated it man I
hated it smells like wood and leaves and
stuff stepmom made swordfish what
the no way dude she was a shake and bake
gal Oo we never really got into Shake
and bake shake and bake reron was the
go-to reron of course the nor noodles
all that stuff and this was back when I
feel like this is changed I don't know
if they Chang regulations but you
remember the chicken back in the day
used to be real veiny you would get
those like red shoes red veins in them a
little bit I think that's just a I might
have been getting genetic modifications
no no veins it was like I know what
you're talking about and I remember
every time we had shaken BAC like what
are you putting in this goddamn chicken
lady over here eating [__] confetti
Chicken on the bone as a kid was always
sometimes it was great and sometimes it
was never picking up your meat at a
Gold's
Gym all Juiced
up pack of chicken yeah pack of chicken
we Patty every once in a while would do
the the the leg and the thigh connect it
it look like a hammer oh yeah that that
was that was that was adult meat I
wasn't eating that it looked like an
uncircumcised hammer you had you had to
file taxes to eat that yeah no way it
was always flabby skin on the end uh I
like a thigh by itself but the drumstick
in the thigh it dude no it was too human
felt like I was eating somebody's
arm get out of here with that not for
the
kid uh all right let's see here this is
from Scotty drgs new $10 home never had
one read is it garbage when I was 11 my
parents went for a 10day trip and left
me home alone
11 yeah that's illegal oh F that's not
even close to being legal there's seven
years off of legal right like 10 days
how do you get yourself to school that's
got to be summer maybe dude imagine
going to school and then going home and
no one's coming back you're just like
that's crazy you got to figure out how
to set an alarm clock make yourself
dinner do laundry breakfast feed the
animals that's we got to pay the bills
and get the lights on you got to balance
the checkbook an 11-year-old sitting
there with a cup of coffee that's in the
checkbook that's too that's crazy that's
crazy holy [__] hope they had a good
time probably didn't bring you back
nothing either I would have destroyed my
parents house everything would have been
a fort I would have had all the homies
over just ter we would have been skating
in the wholeway by the end of it I would
have been insane because I wouldn't have
slept for nine days yeah if it was if I
was by myself my brother was there
that's one thing but still dude I can't
I don't sleep well by myself now looking
out that looking at the front door just
like the darkness of the of the of the
lawn you could just see like a banshee
coming across the street no thank you
yeah uh were you big on were you big on
this can I ask you please if your
parents did go away for a couple days or
whatever and somebody watched you um or
if like like an aunt or an uncle came to
visit were you expecting something were
you expecting your parents to bring you
something back uh yeah for sure it was
always yeah well yes I judged heavily on
it for sure it was always something of
the I mean the only place we I we' go to
the shore all the summer so we never had
big vacations like we did Disney
together once they then my mom started
going to Jamaica with my stepdad every
year or every like maybe like 3 years
four years uh um shout out to sandals
and nism uh bring it back a little
brother huh so uh they would give some
sort of
like thing of the island you know what I
mean you got some wristband from a
nightclub bring me back a one hitter
this is called
reefer this is vitamin G
baby one hit hey show your friends yeah
there's an there a Bob Marley ashtray or
something I get I would get stuff like
that my dad dad went to Mexico a couple
times without me they for sure brought
you a beanie with fake dreads hey M I'm
wearing in school that's F that's a fun
time um always but there better be
something in that suitcase for Hank yeah
but there was only maybe I mean they
only might have went
away four or five times between both my
mom and my dad and my stepmom you know
do you remember when the uh like the
college sweatshirts were big they they
were crew neck sweatshirts
mhm remember when they were big yeah my
dad pen State one yeah my dad had a trip
down in uh like Virginia or West
Virginia and he rolled back with a West
Virginia sweatshirt for my brother and I
got an Old Dominion sweatshirt man this
is a sugar company yeah get out of here
with that dude he's something I can fly
around with dude I hated it yeah oh my
dad would go to South
Carolina uh his business partner had
like a big Ranch down there or whatever
like a big whatever you know big piece
of property they the guy's family all
lived on they go like hunting maybe or
just kind of like I think they were just
going down there and getting [__] up
you know for like four or five days but
always hit South of the Border and had
to bring the kid home lace the kid with
fireworks that's cool m80s bunch of
bottle rockets when those mortars
dropped for the first time I I was the
first kid to have those that's cool and
we were like what the [__] so that was
so every time we went there there was
never any
they worked too much like they ran small
businesses so it was like you can't
every once in a while you know they
sneak away for a weekend somebody's
wedding or something like that I don't
care where you went you better bring me
something back and if you went out to
dinner without me there better be some
leftovers coming back to the crib never
wanted them my parents would have never
given me fireworks which is why I don't
respect them now they're real good time
my parents either that was never going
to happen well again this was my dad
played by his own rules and wanted his
house to be the cool house so that was
like he got us the he got me a mini bike
he got the the BB gun it was like it's
literally fireworks
stereotypical divorced dad who's like my
house is sick playb yeah BB Got The
Whole Nine Yards oh it's going to pull
like he was just really trying to make
his make his house The Chill Spot my dad
had a Playboy collection that could have
gone in the Smithsonian really so nuts I
that was always so creepy to
meepy we're talking boxes bro I get one
or two if to get you know to get the job
done but like a monthly subscription
there was none of that in our house ever
my mom would have freaked out on my dad
yeah I I could tell you the hair styles
of ladies from 1970 to 1995 a worded man
too he like the
Articles and the center
fult uh yeah I don't get that man my dad
was so star for pornography that um we
did something in high school were like
somebody's uh like auto body shop or
something like that and they had just
gotten the Playboy calendars in and they
had a box of them and somebody's uncle
are say hey go take this and I brought
it home and I don't know why I just
thought I was old enough and like my dad
would be cool my dad was in the in the
garage and I was like yo check this out
and he's like what the who the [__] gave
you that mhm yanked it out of my hand
he's like go inside six months lock the
door six months later I found in the
drunk of his
car poor
bastard I'm throwing this out this
disgusting dude you don't need this
filth in this house I'll leave it in the
car you're in a bad spot when you got
gazungas next to the spare tire dude one
of the first I don't know if she was
nude but uh my stepdad had a tow truck
and he was we were Towing one of our
[__] cars to somewhere else like I
think someone he had a tow truck yeah
that's pretty cool mhm man he a race car
driver had get the car had to get the
car toing from it was like a rolloff
truck for the race car to get to from
yeah uh so I was in that we were going
you know I forget we were moving a
cousin's car or something so anybody
anytime needa had a [__] car to move he
had to do it I remember sitting through
I was like seven or eight you want to
come with me I'm like yeah let's go hop
in and the air freshener was like
I want I don't know if she was to there
was a yellow bikini I remember and it
might have been like then then the big V
like the Borat type thing uh either way
either way dude I remember the engine
was running dude the whole trip I'm
like oh yeah you know say what's feel
like all the checks were signed with a
pen that you flip upside down the bikini
comes off wow well you got to think it
was a single guy hillbilly race car
driver that shop was like it was just
him and a bunch of like you know rough
rough neck guys there was gazungas find
a set of cans in there yeah all the all
the big like chest
all shout out those red chest what are
they uh Mac yes a Mac Tool Chest those
things are sweet MH yeah um yeah let's
see here we got time for one more and
then we got to wrap it up uh this is
from Kyle is it garbage to have the
languages you speak on your resume
listed as English and pig
latin that's a tough one dude I listen I
would respect it if that's a joke and
hopefully the guy like if somebody sent
me a resume I was like I speak English
and pigl I'm like this guy gets it funny
he's having a good time he's not taking
himself too serious you know what I mean
that makes sense to me I never
understood it and it used to annoy the
[__] out of me when like my like
girlfriends and friends that were girls
in high school would do it back and
forth I could never I was too dumb do
you get it now no I don't either yeah
and I know you're going to explain it to
me and I'm still not going to get it you
take the end of the word and put it in
the front of the word or whatever it is
put no the front I'm I'm trying of
remember we I remember learning in sixth
grade so like if you
say walk it would be auway yeah that's
so d right you take the W put at the end
and put an A on I didn't have that
quickness to do that I'm well aware
walking through topless walking through
a sesta topless jammed up in long
division what throwing that on me no I I
thought Katie seagull was married to
Jack white man doesn't know know like
you can talk to pigs asking Jeeves over
here yeah this guy's Ram is slowed down
all right we got to wrap it up gang gang
we love you to desk Co up with those
last couple of tickets in DC and grab
tickets for the Philly show if you're in
the tri- state area we'd love to spend
the holidays with you we love you and
we'll see you next week peace